c'est pierre tchernia mon petit bonhomme
de chemin aux éditions stock ce sont des
souvenirs provisoire dites vous-même
pour vous n'est pas sûr de bons
souvenirs c'est parce qu'on on n'est
jamais très sûr des souvenirs enfin au
au fil des années il se modifie se
transforme et ils prennent une autre une
autre allure et puis de toute façon je
veux dire aussi que j'espère avoir
l'occasion d'en fabriquer quelques
autres encore pendant de longues années
et ça a été dur d'écrire ce premier
livre que je trouve que c'est très
bizarre on m'a demandé d'écrire ça je me
suis dit c'est curieux comme demandé 15
estoniens enfin comme tout le monde
écrit ses souvenirs en ce moment avec
les gens du spectacle après avoir été
des m'as-tu-vu deviennent des m'as-tu-vu
je me suis dit bon ballon z'y va
proposer de les écrire par le truchement
d'un magnétophone et puis j'ai pas eu
envie de ça comme j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les livres tant qu'affaire
de voir un livre où mon nom paralysé
comme celui d'un auteur j'ai préféré
l'écrire avec ma plume alors tchernia
c'est ça n'est finalement que la moitié
de vous même la moitié de moi même
germain houde et bien sûr bon je suis
d'origine russe le nom complet était
tchaïkovski et il a toujours été coupé
mon frère déjà quand il était au lycée
ont dû couper son nom en deux et ce qui
est frappant dire c'est que ma mère
s'appelait dufour et j'ai toujours pensé
que c'était une alliance for savoureuse
entre le le samovar et la chopine entre
les frères karamazov et le père
tranquille je suis entre mais
franco-russe coin alors chez vous à
levallois on parlait leurs deux buts à
un
mssa ses souvenirs d'enfant c'est à dire
que vous savez moi j'ai vécu il ya
quelques années dans une famille où on
s'efforçait de ne pas parler devant les
enfants de choses sexuelles ou de mots
qui puissent être un peu en marge de la
wii de l'honnêteté alors mais ma famille
avait eu d'utiliser une sorte d'étrange
jargon qui était leur degré c'est-à-dire
qu'au lieu de dire le dire chapeau on
disait chadha gapeau dogo alors quand on
parlait très vite on disait autour de
moi monsieur je suis un gars d'agadez
guy pouliot et quadruple du du c'est à
dire
galipeau et cocu même caucus il y avait
comme ça des tas de mots qu'ont ces
forces est jamais je n'ai jamais
prononcé devant les enfants ou par l'est
on parlait de manoeuvre abortif par
exemple on parlait de filles mères ont
parlé de fausse couche vous êtes tous
ces bancs aux couches savait comment
mais vous êtes très riche et de la
famille pensait que je ne comprenais
rien mais très vite j'ai très bien
compris est comme ça le leur souci de
respecter mon innocence était entier et
moi j'étais complètement préservée tout
en entendant les mots mais comme je
serais pour ce qu'il voulait dire non
mais c'est façon vous savez dans notre
enfance
il y avait des tas de mots qu'on
n'employait pas ou alors on a pris des
périphrases extraordinaire moi je me
souvenais que j'étais toujours
émerveillé d'entendre parler des
cabinets comme des lieux des zones d le
désert le canton aller au petit coin
dans une eau bois de boulogne tapé des
chalets de nécessité et dans votre
premier pas dans le spectacle bien dire
que cet ofni bergère c'est à dire qu'en
j'avais 15 ans j'étais aux folies
bergère avec un camarade et les folies
bergères sur l'occupation c'est surtout
débute une chose assez extraordinaire
parce que il y avait des fauteuils
profonds comme des tombeaux occupés par
des officiers allemands alors vu
derrière on voyait là on voyait les
locaux du fauteuil une nuque
congestionné et puis au dessus des
cheveux coupés ras et puis ce jour là
y'avait dandy qui est un comique de
music-hall charmant qui présente les
spectacles et brusquement le rideau
s'ouvre et on voit des dames nu qui
cachaient leur petit triangle avec des
cercles de papier sur lequel était
porter un numéro il y avait douze filles
avaient à 2 3 4 5 jusqu'à 12 comme ça et
puis elles dansent sur un petit air de
musique est brusquement dandy fait un
signe elles retournent leur petit numéro
enfin leurs petits pas noueront il n'y
avait plus rien derrière
alors est ce que quand la salle est ce
qu'ils gagnent ces messieurs qui
pourrait nous dire quel numéro d'une de
ces dames est à 15 ans aux folies
bergères on était les observateurs et
moi j'en avais repéré une grande
sculpturale j'ai dit moi sommes
investies chabrol venez ici jeune homme
alors les présents prix alors on sort ça
se rendra le grand jeune homme moi je
venais tout juste heureuse j'arrive et
nikki reconnaissez-vous jeudi madame
c'était le 8
elle retourne en effet sept à huit vous
avez gagné vous avez le droit
d'embrasser la dame je votais de déjà
jeu télévisé comment bien cerné à vous
êtes sorte de mort qu'istres du
spectacle car vous avez vous avez été où
vous êtes comédiens metteurs en scène
reporter producteurs présentateurs
beaucoup de choses dans le monde du
spectacle parce que quand j'étais enfant
je rêvais d'entrer dans le monde du
spectacle et je continue de
m'émerveiller amis mais votre meilleur
souvenir comme c'est lé début du journal
télévisé
or vous ont fait ça fait pas une mais
bon souvenir même nom je crois que mes
meilleurs souvenirs c'est quand même
d'avoir eu l'occasion de de faire des
films parce que je crois que rien n'est
plus bouleversant que le moment où on
est sur un plan les peut alors donner
dans cet ouvrage de vos films je n'aime
pas parler davantage maltais visé alors
que je pensais qu'il fallait puisque on
me proposait d'écrire des souliers
savais pas mais de télévision sur alors
il y avait le direct nous sommes en
direct mais alors le direct à cette
époque c'était autre chose dans les
années 50 notamment vous est arrivé
quelque chose de fâcheux avec madame
volterra ah oui ça c'était je faisais
reportage aux champs elysées sur les
allées des champs elysées et vous savez
on n'avait pas les moyens d'aller très
loin et un samedi pour boucher un trou
n'avait emmené un quart d'heure portage
aux champs elysées alors on interviewe
est le monsieur qui emmenait les ânes
avec les petits enfants dans les
charrettes en interviewait le patron du
manège le patron du guignol enfin vous
voyez là l'importance l'importance de
l'émission confuse et puis je voulais
faire une visite du théâtre marigny
impossible devant madame volterra
pendant les trois jours qui précèdent
l'émission promet des rendez-vous et
puis impossible de la rencontrer et au
moment où l'émission commence quelqu'un
arrive
mon dos alors que je parlais avec mon
film de nos micros et mon fils et je
rentre dans le théâtre et j'interviewe
madame volterra ce sans avoir eu
l'occasion de la rencontrer et à la fin
de l'interview je lui dis madame nous
parler du spectacle allait monter j'ai
dit madame je suis très heureux d'avoir
l'occasion d'entraîner votre théâtre
mais nous savons que vous vous
intéressez pas au théâtre
il y a aussi les choux votre écurie et
célèbre la malheureuse femme avec la
teinture coupez coupez coupez coupez
coupez car ce que je ne savais pas c'est
qu'il y avait deux madame volterra une
cave et le théâtre et l'autre coupé
coupé de coeur moi je suis partie au
micro micro s'accrocher dans les portes
et de couper tout ce mode veille avoir à
l'époque 3642 spectateurs vous êtes
viennent pour les téléspectateurs 10 ans
à majorité des téléspectateurs l'homme
tranquille la télévision l'ami des
enfants l'ami des vieillards
est-ce que vous cultivez c'est cette
image de manas est une base sont pas du
tout du tout jeu qu'on s'attendait pas
du tout à être l'ami des enfants ne
voient une vache et en enlevant une
jolie femme se dit à mon petit garçon
vous aimons madame qui peut paraître ce
soit vous donc à faire c'est joli mais
je suis je suis je suis rassurant et
j'ai souvent lu sous la plume de nos
amis critiques de télévision que je
serai la bonhomie souriante
c'est peut-être vous votre ronde sur ce
la rondeur manger